how big is your shelter that you have
i'm not asking specifics but it's
something that can it fit
15 people or family members or i don't
have an underground ship or you don't
have an underground shelter okay i used
to in my place in maryland but this is a
new uh
you know so you're a little bit more
optimistic right now than you used to be
uh
i wouldn't say that i'd say i'm i'm i'm
less optimistic but i'm uh
it's not a question of uh of of optimism
but uh the uh then why don't you have
one you know well because i think that
that's the last thing you really need
you know i'd rather put the money into
stockpiling food
raising chickens you know uh you know i
don't think radioactive fallout uh you
know bunkering yourself uh i think this
is based on a myth i just explained how
a counterforce attack would work no no i
i totally get what you said i i get what
you said and you you you actually
i'm hoping putin doesn't watch his
podcast because your other podcast was
translated into russian and our russian
channel that's got a few hundred
thousand subscribers but uh so
what i'm asking you is the following
so you in your mind this is how i
process it feel free to push back if you
don't have a shelter at this point of
your life and you are probably wealthier
today that you can afford it versus when
you used to be in maryland today you
could probably get a shelter if you
wanted to
is it because you think
it's more likely for us to have a
super emp attack before a nuclear attack
is that kind of
i think it's much more likely that we
would have a super easy okay that's why
cyber attack and that that faction you
know is arguing for vladimir putin's ear
and trying to get him to listen to them
instead of going to
i got a nuclear war yeah so so okay
so so but but my but the reason i don't
have my shelter anymore has not because
i'm more optimistic today i don't have
my shelter because the obama
administration punished me
for criticizing their national security
policies and canceled my defense
contracts okay so i couldn't afford
my farm in maryland and the and the
state of maryland in 2008 raised the
taxes on people who had farms so high
that the people who had been living
there for 300 years had to sell their
farms is that literally the reason why
you don't know that is the reason if i
if i if i had not uh if i had not had to
give up my farm in maryland i would
definitely still have it today i had a
shelter in that farm that could have
survived a
uh a one megaton attack
attack happening relatively close by uh
you know the house was designed to
survive that and it was a a better set
up but you know i ended up uh like a lot
of people you know uh got coming out of
that so that i uh you know i'm not as
prosperous today as i used to be thanks
to the obama administration
and uh you know and financially i never
came back to that so i'm doing the best
i can
i'm not a rich guy i'm doing the best i
can with what i what i've got i'm very
uh i'm satisfied uh you know with uh
with what i've with what i've done we've
uh
uh this new
farm where we're setting up uh you know
is actually further away from washington
because i'm less optimistic that
washington isn't gonna get nuked you
know than i was before you know i've
moved my family to a what i think is a
safer safer location so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]
you